[Music]
according to the insurer hiscox
between 2019 and 2020 the share of
companies
affected by cyber security event fell at
the same time though losses from
successful attacks are skyrocketing
garden variety attacks are on the
decline but highly sophisticated ones
are becoming a major concern both for
companies and all levels of government
the more targeted attacks are sometimes
used for disruption
sometimes for espionage and features
people with the skills of russia's
apt-29
and apt-28 groups russia has not paid to
attack
crippled ukrainian infrastructure and a
string of global corporations
the solarwinds hack which seems to have
been a russian espionage operation
reached large parts of the us government
as well as private companies
but state-sponsored attacks may be the
easier problem
sometimes the technology leaks to
criminals who might recklessly do even
more damage than belligerent states
the urgent question becomes can nations
agree to limit the proliferation of
cyber weapons
much like they have done with nuclear
weapons
how concerned are you about cyber
attacks let us know in our poll
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from aei